[Musique]
oui mademoiselle liliane à st voulez
vous prendre pour époux monsieur
rodolphe julien meyer et chinoises ont
repris au noir des etats-unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était parmi les mariés de l'été plus
de 500 invités rien que la famille et
tous encore n'ont pas pu venir en tout
presque 300 personnes une traîne de
plusieurs mètres le grand mariage du
mois d'août à longuenesse près de
saint-omer
liliane et rodolphe ont sept enfants
[Musique]
il y en ait rodolphe son jus temps de la
famille de l'oncle boglione rien que les
cousins ils sont plus de cent cinq ans
et chaque année la famille s'agrandit et
cette fois ils étaient venus des vosges
de paris ou des hautes-alpes avec femme
enfants et caravanes
pas question de manquer le mariage de
lanquetot rodolphe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'après lui
chavez
chez les gitans les choses ne se passent
pas comme chez les gadjé les non gitans
l'homme est le seul chef de famille
c'est lui qui choisit sa femme et qu'il
apprend le mariage est l'occasion d'une
immense fête de famille
rien que cela le mariage de liliane et
de rodolphe était prévu depuis l'an
dernier et chacun a pris ses
dispositions pour être à longuenesse le
15 ou alors soldeurs marchands de
chaises jantes cirque artisans ou
artistes chacun à clé sa caravane et
pris la direction du nord là bas on
savait qu'on allait retrouver les
cousins les frères et les parents
mangeaient le mouton noir du mousseux
pour fêter le mariage entendre la mariée
chanter et aussi entendre la guitare du
pouzin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on en profitera pour prendre rendez vous
pour les baptêmes gennevilliers à gap à
limoges ou à longuenesse
on n'a pas tellement souvent l'occasion
de s'amuser en famille chez les gitans
[Musique]
et
sera pas fâché jamais lieu sait-on
jamais
ap
[Musique]
et manger
j'ai toujours le même que tu te
[Musique]
allons voyons
les plages
[Musique]
on ne peut pardonner
passagers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]